i heard something weird about you you
your playstation broke
and you you were under warranty all you
had to do is uh
take it in and they would uh give it
give you a new one for free a free
replacement well
that's not exactly how you went out and
bought a whole new playstation
just uh i'm wondering if you're being
frivolous with your money
yeah probably but listen it's all i
really do in life
is is play my playstation when you look
back on your life someday
you know and i understand people enjoy
games and things what do you think
you'll look back and have regrets that
you spend so much time
you do okay yes yes i agree a lot of
things
yes i know you always had fantasies of
of becoming a film director
why not yes spend this time making a
short film don't you think that it would
become
beneficial toward that goal yes there
there are two ideas i have that uh the
the
um overall theme is sort of mental
illness
mental illness i like that i like i like
movies about mental illness i'm trying
to does the guy sit in his house and
play
video games all day no
not yet no this is why i don't you know
what
i've given up on all that so that's why
i don't do any of it what
you know what i learned about you you
give up easily this is true
uh tell me about something interesting i
heard about you
when we were in los angeles a year ago i
heard that you were going to pitch a
movie to ted sarandos at netflix
and ted had to cancel at the last minute
yes
what were you going to say let me hear
the pitch
all right god i hate you are you worried
that someone will hear this idea and
steal it
is that what's going on uh not
copyrighted
it's it's two things it's that and but
it's also sounded like a complete idiot
and uh you know i think it's too late
for that i i think i know i know
but i know kind of
right how are you gonna get better if
you don't start pitching my pitch is
worse than gary's
[Laughter]
yes gary jd i'm not going to throw you
under the bus but
i do know that there were three ideas
that he had he had a documentary
he had a comedy and he had an action
thriller so
which one of those would you would have
been your top pitch i'm looking at the
synopsis of all of them right now but i
want to let him decide
i think the i i like the documentary the
most you know i've always been
fascinated by
celebrities who like you know they're so
popular and whatnot and then they sort
of end up disappearing
they get out of the public spotlight
they're wreck loses
so uh you know someone like say axl rose
and document them and you know try and
figure out why
you know what led them to this lifestyle
how they live so
everybody knows reclusive i mean axel
rose probably doesn't put himself out
there in front of the paparazzi that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
he's he's not out there like that's
called being normal
he's not an [ __ ] who's busy uh trying
to get himself on social media every
minute
well he is on social media actually but
reclusive doesn't mean you don't talk to
the media
that means you don't go out all right
okay you put you all right all right
okay you punched holes in this one all
right and then leave me alone thank you
thank you and most of these people if
they are reclusive
you can't get to them
well that would be part of you know the
journey i guess sounds to me like the
idea is he's going to bother a bunch of
people who don't want to be bothered
right okay open the door it's jd
open up